ces grosses dettes alors on va expliquer
ça au téléspectateurs peut-être qu'on va
faire un casse pas le temps j'ai pas
besoin d'un casse-tête on va faire un
capteur de ton s'il le faut le prendre
tout expliqué ça va qu'est-ce qui se
passe 500000 €. non mais j'en ai
beaucoup plus mais arrête dans la
descends d'un mec dans la rue il me dit
que tu lui donnes l'oseille beaucoup de
gens qui me disent des bêtises donc
bizarre parce qu'ils m'ont montré les
papiers ah bah alors c'est on a les
mêmes tierce Polyte alors vas-y alors
voilà donc il faut structurer une petite
dette donc petit
500000 beaucoup plus mais il faut
restructures restructurer une partie
pour pouvoir avancer et aller de l'avant
allez 500000 c'est une partie de l'avant
maintenant 10e de la dette j'ai deux non
non non t'as pas sonné alors
j'ai réussi
tu dis pas que des conneries c'est
parfaitement lucide contrairement à ce
que j'ai dit il y a deux minutes
non pas du tout je rigolais 5 millions
et tu en as purgé une grande partie il
en reste à peu près 3 non dans beaucoup
moins mais on peut en commun
[Applaudissements]
donc gentiment enfin gentiment non pas
gentiment puisque la réponse a été non
donc vous avez répondu négativement à
cette caution que je vous avais demandé
poliment je vais dans expliquer le
spectateurs c'est très simple il voulait
il voulait et je Lisieux je vous dis
tout je vais poser cette question sur
Twitter on s'en fout dois-je être
caution pour Benjamin Castaldi
peut-être qu'il y a des gens à qui vous
allez faire de la peine euh
il m'a demandé il m'a demandé il va
emprunter 500000 il faut que je sois
caution je suis 500000 €. c'est ce que
je viens de dire ça veut dire que si il
paye pas bah oui c'est moi qui vais
payer ça c'est le principe de la caution
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire et si si
c'est moi qui paye est-ce que ça veut
dire plus personne n'est payé dans TPMP
parce que je vais devoir récupérer
[Applaudissements]
j'attends la vie de mes amis et les
téléspectateurs
peu importe donc là je vais m'en
sortirai quand même mais comment je vais
trouver une solution qui tu vas encore
voler
[Rires]
ou pas
donc voilà donc j'ai compris
donc merci monsieur
je ne tends pas la main je tends tout
mon corps
[Applaudissements]
de l'argent une fois je l'ai déjà dit à
22h22 et je vous l'ai rendu à
22h3700
argent il croit qu'il va arriver on va
lui donner
voilà
alors explique les spectateurs c'est
signé parce qu'on comprend pas non bah
en fait on peut l'occasion quand on est
un peu connu qu'on a des garanties quand
j'avais des garanties ce qui n'est plus
mon gars mais vous avez beaucoup de
garanties
je compte sur vous pour me garantir du
tout va chez Darty et donc quand on est
quand on a une garantie on peut signer
c'est qu'en fait on demande des jetons
et on se dit un papier une
reconnaissance et bien sûr tu payes
après tu payes après ou alors tu payes
pas tu reviens
est-ce que toi si tu ne peux pas
rembourser est-ce que il y a une clause
qui permettrait de sécuriser Cyril la
clause elle est très simple dans ma
gueule exactement
dans une CAF pendant une petite année
avec des amis à moi après
il y a moyen mais alors voilà pas grand
chose c'est l'équivalent de 2 4 4
avant de dire non est-ce que vous avez
hésité une seconde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
envisager d'oublier l'histoire de
caution et de gentiment par amitié
un cadeau un don un cadeau merci